what do you think is the meaning of it
all what's the meaning of life jordan
peterson
you've we've defined it many many times
throughout this conversation the
adventure along the route man
and i would say where's that adventure
to be found
in faith
what's the faith
the highest value is love and truth is
it's handmade
that's a statement of faith right
because you can't tell
you have to act it out to see if it's if
it's true yeah and so you can't even
find out without and that's so peculiar
you have to make the commitment a priory
yeah it's like a marriage it's the same
thing
it's like well is this the person for me
oh that's the wrong question
how do i find out if this is the person
for me
by binding myself to them
well maybe the same thing's true of life
right you bind yourself to it
and the tighter you bind yourself to it
the more you find out what it is
and that's like a radical embrace and
it's it's a really radical embrace
that's the crucifix symbol and more than
that because like i said the the full
passion story
isn't death it isn't even unjust death
it isn't even unjust death and the
crucifixion of the innocent which is
really getting pretty bad
it's
unjust
torturous
innocent
death
attendant upon betrayal and tyranny
followed by hell well that's a hell of a
thing to radically um embrace it's like
bring it on
i think a lot of people
put truth as the highest ideal
and
think they can get to that ideal
while living in a place of cynicism and
ultimately escape from life and hiding
from life afraid of life and it's a it's
beautifully put that uh
love
is the the highest ideal to reach for
and truth is it's handmade i try i
thought about that for a long time right
this hierarchy of ideal
and the thing about truth that bitter
truth let's say that cynical truth is it
can
break the shackles of naivety
and actually
a burnt cynicism is a moral improvement
over a blind naivety
even though
one is in some ways positive but only
because it's protected and the other is
bitter and dark but still better
but you're not done at that point you're
just barely started it's like you're
cynical
you're not cynical enough
it's like how cynical are you are you
i'm an auschwitz prison guard level of
cynical
because you have to be you have to go
down pretty deep into the weeds before
you find that part of you but
you can find it if you want and then you
think well i want to stop this
well that was the question you posed in
some sense you're obsessed with say what
happened on these mass scale
catastrophes
in the communist countries it's like
well
millions of people participated
so you could have
and maybe you would have enjoyed it so
what part of that is you
and you can find it
if you want
yeah it's it's all there the prisoner
the interrogator
the
pontius pilate
all of it all of it and that's all of it
is inside us yeah and you just have to
look
and once you do maybe eventually you can
find the love
jordan you're an incredible human being
i'm deeply honored you would talk to me
thank you for being a truth seeker in
this world and thank you for the love
hey
thanks for the invitation man
you